♪
PETE: WELCOME BACK.
WELL, THE MONTH OF AUGUST WAS
BAD ONE FOR JOE BIDEN WITH HIS
APPROVAL RATINGS SINKING TO AN
ALL-TIME LOW AS THE WHITE HOUSE
TRIES TO MANAGE MULTIPLE CRISES.
MANY OF THEIR OWN MAKING.
FROM AFGHANISTAN TO THE CHAOS AT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
ON TOP OF THAT, THE LATEST JOBS
REPORT SHOWS EMPLOYMENT IN
AUGUST MISSED EXPECTATIONS BY
ALMOST HALF A MILLION.
OUTNUMBERED COHOST AND FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
KAYLEIGH McENANY IS HERE TO
REACT.
GOOD MORNING, SO GREAT TO HAVE
YOU, AS ALWAYS.
>> GOOD MORNING.
PETE: GOOD MORNING.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THIS
KIND OF STUNNING COLLAPSE, AND
DOES IT SURPRISE YOU AT ALL?
>> LOOK, IT DOESN’T SURPRISE ME
BECAUSE WE ELECTED A PRESIDENT
FROM A BASEMENT.
HE WAS NOT TESTED.
THE ONLY CHALLENGE HE HAD WAS ON
THAT DEBATE STAGE WHERE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ABSOLUTELY
TROUNCED HIM IN THAT FINAL
DEBATE.
BUT WE ELECTED SOMEONE WITHOUT
ANY REAL SCRUTINY WHO HAD, BY
THE WAY, A HORRIBLE RECORD IN
FOREIGN POLICY.
WE’VE ALL HEARD THE GATES’ QUOTE
ABOUT HIM BEING WRONG ON EVERY
MAJOR FOREIGN POLICY DECISION.
SO ALL OF A SUDDEN, A FEW
MONTHS, EIGHT MONTHS IN, PEOPLE
REALIZE, OH, WAIT, INFLATION’S
COMING.
A 39% APPROVAL RATING ON THE
ECONOMY.
OH, WAIT, COVID.
HE WASN’T PREPARED FOR THAT
EITHER, ALL OF A SUDDEN HIS POLL
NUMBERS TANKING THERE.
CRIME, IMMIGRATION, YOU NAME IT.
AND THEN THE AFGHANISTAN
WITHDRAWAL WHICH I THINK JUST
CRYSTALLIZED IN EVERYONE’S MIND
HOW INCOMPETENT, HOW MUCH OF A
BAFFOON THIS PRESIDENT ACTUALLY
IS.
PETE: YEAH, WHAT IS IT ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN, BECAUSE CRIME
NUMBERS HAVE BEEN THERE, THE
BORDER, WE’VE HAD THE IMAGES,
THEY’VE BEEN SHOWN, INFLATION,
UNEMPLOYMENT, NOT TO MENTION A
NUMBER OF OTHER ISSUES HAVE ALL
BEEN THERE.
BUT AFGHANISTAN SEEMS TO HAVE
REALLY LEFT AN IMPRINT ON PEOPLE
AND HAVE SENT HIS NUMBERS SOUTH.
WHAT IS IT ABOUT THAT?
>> I CAN TELL YOU WHAT IT IS,
PETE.
YOU KNOW, CONTRARY TO WHAT THE
LEFT SAYS, THEY SAY THEY DON’T
HAVE ANY BINDING PRINCIPLES AS
AMERICANS AS THEY TRY TO WIPE
AWAY THE THINGS THAT UNITE US,
BUT ONE OF THOSE CENTRAL
PRINCIPLES IS CARING FOR ONE
ANOTHER, IT’S NOT LEAVING
ANOTHER AMERICAN BEHIND.
IT’S CENTRAL TO WHO WE ARE, I
DON’T HAVE TO TELL YOU, PETE IF,
IT’S CENTRAL TO THE MILITARY AS
YOU KNOW WELL.
SO I THINK WHEN I SAW THE
POLLING AND IT WAS
EXTRAORDINARILY HIGH NUMBERS OF
PEOPLE WHO SAID, NO, I DON’T
WANT TO LEAVE AMERICANS BEHIND,
AND EVEN A MAJORITY SAYING I
DON’T WANT TO LEAVE AFGHAN
ALLIES LIKE THE INTERCEPTER WHO
HELPED YOU -- INTERPRETER WHO
HELPED YOU AND SO MANY OTHERS.
WHEN WE LOST A WAR WE FOUGHT FOR
20 YEARS, LEFT AMERICANS BEHIND,
AFGHANS HANGING FROM PLANES, 13
U.S. SERVICE MEMBERS DEAD AFTER
18 MONTHS OF NOT LOSING A
SERVICE MEMBER, I THINK IT RUBS
AMERICANS THE WRONG WAY.
PETE: YOU’RE RIGHT.
AND THE IMAGES ARE SO STARK
WHETHER IT’S THE CHECKING OF THE
WATCH OR THE BOWING OF THE HEAD
OR, AS YOU REFERRED TO, CLINGING
TO PLANES AND FALLING FROM THE
AIR.
AND EVEN AS WE WERE TALKING, WE
SHOWED THE TALIBAN FLAG NOW
FLYING FROM OUR EQUIPMENT RIGHT
BEFORE OUR EYES.
IT FEELS LIKE AMERICA’S DIGNITY,
HONOR, HAS BEEN SHAKEN TO ITS
CORE.
>> YEAH.
YOU JUST HIT THE NAIL ON THE
HELD THERE TOO, PETE.
IT’S COMPASSION, AND I THINK JOE
BIDEN MISLED THE COUNTRY.
I’M THIS BIG COMPASSIONATE GUY,
HE HAD SOME TEARY-EYED MOMENTS
AND AMERICANS SAID I WANT THAT
GUY.
BUT THEN HE FIND OUT -- WE FIND
OUT WHEN WE ASKED ABOUT THE
AFGHANS, HE SAID THAT HAPPENED
FOUR OR FIVE DAYS AGO.
AFTER A AFTERGANS -- AFGHANS
WERE BEING KILLED, NO ONE IS
BEING KILLED.
THE CHECKING THE WATCH.
THIS MAN IS STUBBORN, HE’S NOT
CARING, IN FACT, I WOULD ARGUE
HE’S CRUEL AS WE’VE SEEN --
PETE: YEAH, WELL SAID.
43% APPROVAL RATING, THAT’S
INCREDIBLY LOW WHEN YOU CONSIDER
HOW YOUNG, ULTIMATELY, HIS TERM
IS.
IF YOU WERE TO LOOK AT WHERE
THEY WOULD LOOK TO RECOVER THAT
NUMBER, WHERE DOES AN
ADMINISTRATION LIKE THIS GO TO
SAY IS, ALL RIGHT -- RIGHT NOW
THEY’RE TRYING TO GO TO THE $3.5
TRILLION GREEN NEW DEAL BILL.
WHERE DO THEY TURN TO TRY TO
BRING THAT NORTH?
>> I THINK THEY’LL TRY TO TURN
TO THAT BILL, BUT THE PROBLEM IS
EVEN POLLING SHOWS AMERICANS ARE
ALL OF A SUDDEN A LITTLE RIFLED
BY SPENDING.
THEY REALIZE THAT THIS
EXORBITANT SPENDING IS TIED TO
INFLATION.
I DON’T THINK THEY HAVE ANYWHERE
TO TURN BECAUSE AN
ADMINISTRATION IF LIKE THIS
NEEDS TO AUTOCORRECT, NEEDS TO
ACKNOWLEDGE, WAIT, TRUMP’S
BORDER POLICIES WERE WORKING.
WAIT, THE WAY HE WANTED TO GET
OUT OF AFGHANISTAN WAS THE RIGHT
WAY.
WAIT, HIS ECONOMIC POLICIES WERE
WORKING.
THERE’S MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR
MORE PEOPLE, BUT IT TAKES AN
AUTOCORRECT.
IT TAKES SAYING, WAIT, THAT GUY
WAS DOING SOMETHING RIGHT, AND I
DON’T THINK OUR STUBBORN
PRESIDENT HAS THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT.
PETE: NO, YOU’RE RIGHT, THEY
BELIEVE WHAT THEY’RE DOING EVEN
IF IT’S UNDERMINING AND CRUSHING
OUR CUB IN THE PROCESS.
KAYLEIGH, YOU’RE GOING TO BE ON
THE BIG SATURDAY SHOW 5 P.M.
HERE ON THE BIG CHANNEL.